In the last quiz, we transformed the function f of x equals x squared, into the
function f of x equals x squared minus 2. And we saw that the way this affects
our graph is, it moves it down by 2 units. We called this a vertical shift
downward. But remember, we're trying to help Athena with her function. And I'm
not sure yet if we're going to need to move things vertically. We do know,
however, that she's going to want to move her function horizontally. So why
don't we try that for a second. So let's say that, once again, we start out
with the function, f of x equals x squared. This time however, I know that I
want to get a graph that's exactly the same as this one, but shifted over to
the right by 3 units. What equation do I need for this new graph? Please write
it right here.